Disney's Oscar-winning blockbuster "Frozen"...
...became the highest grossing animated movie of all time...
...after opening in Japan over the weekend.
The film about a fearless fairy tale princess...
...has earned an estimated 398 million dollars at the domestic box office...
...and 674 million internationally, making it the first billion-dollar film for the studio...
...and one of the top ten highest grossing movies of all time.
Here's a look at the other top grossing films of all time.
In fifth place, there's the tale of an overprotective clownfish named Marlin,...
...who, along with his sidekick Dory, played by Ellen Degeneres,...
...searches for his abducted son, Nemo,...
...all the while learning to take risks and become more adventurous.
In fourth place, with more than 970 million dollars in sales worldwide,...
..."Despicable Me 2" has become the most profitable film...
...in the 100-year history of Universal Studios.
Then there's longtime favorite, Disney's "The Lion King."
Since its release 20 years ago,...
..."Lion King" has earned more than 987 million dollars at the box office worldwide.
Still, it can't compete with "Toy Story 3."
This franchise has gone to infinity and beyond,...
...grossing just over a billion dollars since its release in 2010.
But now Woody and Buzz have been knocked into second place...
...by the tale of honest quest in the frozen kingdom of Arendelle.